the first change to understand is the
speed in the old days of Giotto crisis
you had a certain amount of time to
respond to this crisis you you'd get a
call from a journalist you'd say we're
running this story and you talk to your
team and you'd have a 24-hour news cycle
if you will until you had to give a
response today I get a call from Harvey
Levin at TMZ and says I'm running the
story in one minute give me a response
and so that just the speed the
metabolism of the media has gone crazy
the second thing is journalistic
standards in this sad time as we watch
major newspapers go out of business be
for sale lose their circulation the one
thing that's really lost is journalistic
standards and credibility and a lot of
people out there in this world
disseminating the news particularly
bloggers not all of them some of them
are great don't have journalistic
standards and they're more interested in
speed than accuracy and when somebody is
inaccurate and they don't care it makes
it really hard to overcome that with the
truth whereas if I talk to the New York
Times and say that's not true and I can
prove it I can either get a correction
or I can get him to stop running
something it's not going to stop Perez
Hilton what am I you know there's a the
legal term is judgment-proof a lot of
these bloggers living in their parents
basement with a laptop and their boxer
shorts what am I taking the laptop or
the boxer shorts if I sue these guys